und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka guten
abend zweiter oktober der exit monat hat
begonnen
bereits in zwei wochen findet dazu der
entscheidenden eu gipfel statt
so kurz vor toresschluss hat
großbritanniens premier bruce johnston
nun erstmals etwas konkretere vorschläge
vorgelegt wie ein chaos wie exit ohne
abkommen mit der eu doch noch vermieden
werden könnte
eine karte er es damit nicht immerhin
ist der seit 70 tagen im amt
auch ist unklar ob man die vorschläge
überhaupt vorschläge nennen kann
sonst spricht zwar von einem kompromiss
setzt den anderen 27 eu mitgliedern
zugleich aber verbal die pistole auf die
brust
in seiner rede heute vor dem parteitag
der tories klang das dann doch sehr nach
vogel friss oder stirb take it or leave
it andreas stadt berichtet den br- exit
liefern das parteitagsmotto eine
mammut-aufgabe und als der politik
zirkus schon weitergezogen ist wird klar
große pläne die entscheidende
veränderung fehlanzeige
zuvor gab es lange schlangen vor der
halle sinnbild für das vertrauen in den
hoffnungsträger der konservativen balls
jones die vergangenen tage beherrschten
korruptionsvorwürfe die schlagzeilen
dazu soll er immer wieder frauen
unsittlich berührt haben den delegierten
egal nur eins zählt bei seiner ersten
parteitagsrede als premier sei nur
versprechen das land wird am 31 oktober
die eu verlassen koste es was es wolle
deshalb legen wir heute in brüssel
vernünftige und konstruktive vorschläge
vor einen kompromiss
es wird so unter keinen umständen
kontrollen an oder nahe der grenze
zwischen irland und nordirland geben
die alternative ist ein brett ohne
abkommen was wir nicht wollen aber wir
sind bereit
auf dieses konkrete britischer angebot
wartet die eu seit wochen johnsons
erstes dass er dreisterweise gleich als
sein letztes bezeichnet trägt sein
chefunterhändler am mittag nach brüssel
der kern der vorschläge großbritannien
will als ganzes die europäische zoll
union verlassen fordert eine
sonderregelung für den nordirischen
landes teil der im eu binnenmarkt
bleiben soll zeitlich beschränkte
notwendige zollformalitäten würden
fernab der grenze erledigt kompliziert
illusorisch unzureichend so die reaktion
die auf der europäischen seite am
meisten zählt die irische weil es um
frieden und wohlstand auf der irischen
insel geht was ich bislang gesehen habe
ist nicht vielversprechend es scheint
keine basis für ein abkommen aber wir
werden weiter miteinander regiert
talking auch die eu kommission
signalisierte verhandlungsbereitschaft
den dragset liefern da scheint johnson
keinen schritt weiter trotzdem feiern
sie ihren star der sich zum kämpfer
stilisiert der es mit dem establishment
mit dem parlament aufnimmt dass er
zurück in london noch mal in eine
zwangspause schickt diesmal für wenige
tage was rechtlich einwandfrei ist
die nächste parlamentswahl innenpolitik
scheint für johnson wichtiger als ein
deal mit der eu nach brüssel zu unserem
korrespondenten stefan life hat man das
etwas vertiefen wie die reaktionen von
europäischer seite aussehen
erstmal sind in dieser stadt noch alle
damit beschäftigt diese unglaublich
komplizierten vorschläge die aus london
heute gekommen sind zu verstehen aber
die ersten reaktionen die bewegen sich
irgendwo zwischen skepsis und ablehnung
was erst einmal alle in brüssel gut
finden ist dass es jetzt einen vorschlag
gibt den man wirklich verhandlungs basis
nennen kann was zweitens aber alle sehr
schwierig finden ist dass durch die
vorschläge von boris johnson johnson
plötzlich zwei grenzen entstehen eine
zollgrenze zwischen irland und
nordirland und dann eine zweite eine
waren grenze zwischen der irischen insel
und großbritannien da müsste alles
kontrolliert werden was dann waren von
großbritannien in richtung irland geht
ob es den eu standards entspricht und
das wird doch unglaublich kompliziert
und drittens was hier in brüssel auf
große ablehnung stößt das ist das recht
was boris johnson dem nordirischen
parlament einräumen will
nämlich das recht alle paar jahre zu
entscheiden ob nordirland wirklich bei
diesen regelungen bleiben will ohne dass
die eu dabei eine mitsprache bekommt
also nach einem großen durchbruch ich
das hier heute noch nicht aber man wird
sich vermutlich brüssel nicht vorwerfen
lassen wollen das nicht ernsthaft zu
prüfen oder ja genau auf dieses schwarze
peter spiel hat hier in brüssel
natürlich keiner lust man will boris
johnson nicht das argument am ende
liefern dass die eu nicht bereit war zu
verhandeln deswegen hat der
kommissionspräsident juncker auch heute
im telefonat mit boris johnson zugesagt
dass man jetzt bereit ist tag und nacht
über das was gekommen ist zu verhandeln
nur es bleibt nicht viel zeit dafür in
zwei wochen ist eu gipfel
das wäre dann so eine art schoder und
bis dahin müsste der deal erreicht sein
da braucht es dann die zustimmung der
anderen eu-mitglieder
sollte es zum deal kommen muss muss
boris johnson damit dann ja noch mal ins
britische unterhaus auch das ist kein
selbstläufer
naja und dann ist am 29 in 29 tagen das
bag cit datum was heutiger sicht nach
wie vor nicht zu sagen ob das ein break
cit mit eagle wird ein brett ohne deal
oder ob es noch mal eine neue
verlängerung gibt dankeschön nach
brüssel stefan leifert der drohende
brachse der schon jetzt beeinträchtigte
deutsch-britische handel trägt auch dazu
bei dass die prognosen für die deutsche
wirtschaft nicht mehr so sonnig sind wie
in den letzten jahren und es war ja
tatsächlich ein langer zeitraum fast
zehn jahre in denen durchgehend positive
zahlen verkündet wurden wachstum export
arbeitsmarkt es lief eigentlich immer
gut für deutschland
diese goldenen zeiten scheinen vorbei
das ist jedenfalls die diagnose der
führenden wirtschaftsforschungsinstitute
wie in berlin heute ihr herbstgutachten
vorstellten verbunden mit forderungen an
die politik mehr dazu von patricia
widenmayer
eigentlich sind die wirtschaftsforscher
immer deutlich mit ihrer kritik klar in
der sprache doch besondere zeiten wie
derzeit in der klimakrise erfordern
besondere wortschöpfungen wie ökonomen
sprechen von einem internet empor ahlen
optimierungs problem es gibt die
interessen der heutige heute der heute
lebenden und es gibt die interessen der
morgen leben
die regierung sie hat also derzeit ein
inter temporal es optimierungs problem
das heißt sie wird zeitgleich mehr
klimaschutz mit mehr wirtschaftswachstum
verknüpfen kaum möglich meinen die
forscher
wenn wir etwas wirksam für den
klimaschutz tun wollen dann geht das
notwendigerweise heute mit
konsumverzicht einher da geht gar kein
weg dran vorbei doch der private konsum
ist derzeit genau das was noch für
leichtes wirtschaftswachstum sorgt in
deutschland wurde die prognose zwar nach
unten korrigiert aber immerhin es gibt
noch wachstum 0,5 prozent in diesem jahr
und 10 1 prozent im nächsten wir
schreiben so an der rezession vorbei
aber also wir sind nicht drin und
geraten
nach unserer prognose auch nicht daran
doch bedingt durch die exit und
weltweiter handelsstreits ist derzeit
kaum langfristige planung möglich das
merkt auch die firma ziehl abegg aus dem
kreis hohenlohe in baden württemberg
hier werden hoch moderne lüftungssysteme
hergestellt die aufträge kommen immer
spärlicher rein es herrscht allgemein
große unsicherheit
die diskussion zwischen usa und china
ist bestimmt nicht förderlich moment
sondern das reduziert natürlich das
geschäft jeder ist vorsichtig ein tweet
von dem hand war ich dass die börsen
einknicken der wirtschaftsminister
versucht zu beruhigen noch wirke sich
der abschwung gern nicht auf den
arbeitsmarkt aus wir brauchen dringend
jetzt wachstumspolitik mit strukturellen
verbesserungen steuerentlastungen und
bürokratieabbau weil wir eben einen
abschwung aber keine konjunkturkrise
erleben
doch das alles reiche nicht die
regierung dürfe zudem nicht weiter an
der schwarzen null festhalten
ein festhalten an der schwarzen null als
selbstzweck wäre allerdings grundfalsch
dem abschwung hinterher zu sparen
verschärft die probleme
deutliche worte die in der
bundesregierung heute wohl keiner gerne
gehört hat mit dem klima paket der
bundesregierung geht es jetzt in den
nachrichten erst mal weiter hat das
bundeskabinett hat heute den
finanzierungsrahmen für das klima paket
beschlossen
mit insgesamt mehr als 54 milliarden
euro bis 2023
das rund 200 seiten starke
klimaschutzprogramm selbst hat das
kabinett noch nicht verabschiedet laut
csu war das programm in seiner letzten
version erst heute morgen an die
ressorts gegangen und soll bis zur
kabinettssitzung kommende woche noch
intensiv durchgearbeitet werden
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
hat zum tag der deutschen einheit 25
frauen und männer für ihre verdienste um
das land ausgezeichnet
unter ihnen frühere ddr bürgerrechtler
rainer eppelmann der sich intensiv um
die aufarbeitung der sed-diktatur
kümmerte ausgezeichnet wurden auch
rockmusiker udo lindenberg und der
astronaut alexander gerst
die usa und die eu werfen sich seit
jahren gegenseitig subventionen und
wettbewerbsverzerrungen im
konkurrenzkampf zwischen den
flugzeugbauern boeing und airbus vor
jetzt hat die welthandelsorganisation
wto den usa das recht zugesprochen als
vergeltungsmaßnahme strafzölle auf eu
waren in höhe von 75 milliarden dollar
jährlich zu erheben und gerade eben kam
die meldung dass die usa von diesem
recht auch gebrauch machen wollen die eu
hat ihrerseits bei der wto beantragt
strafzölle auf us waren erheben zu
dürfen
die entscheidung darüber steht noch aus
am jahrestag des mordes an dem
washington post journalisten cascioli
hat die un sonderberichterstatter in
calama saudi arabien schwer beschuldigt
sie sagte niemand dürfe mit mord davon
kommen auch nicht so eine einflussreiche
macht aktivisten freunde und familie
carstens versammelten sich nahe dem
saudischen konsulat in istanbul
dort hat er ein agenten team den
journalisten abgefangen und getötet
saudi arabiens kronprinz bin salman
bestreitet davon gewusst zu haben
der tschechischer schlagersänger karel
gottes dem alter von 80 jahren in prag
gestorben
karel gott stand in seiner
internationalen karriere fast sechs
jahrzehnte auf der bühne feierte große
erfolge etwa mit der titelmelodie der
biene maja und zahlreichen anderen
die ganze
ein ergebnis vom zweiten spieltag der
fußball-champions-league borussia
dortmund hat am abend bei slavia prag 2
zu 0 gewonnen und jetzt die zahlen vom
lotto am mittwoch sie lauten wie immer
ohne gewähr
3 26 29 31 33 48 superzahl 0 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 55 7
und jetzt wetteraussichten für morgen
bei neun bis 15 grad entwickeln sich
zwischen dem emsland und dem bayerischen
wald einige regenschauer sonst wechseln
sonne und wolken einander ab und es
bleibt trocken
bis zum wochenende regnet es immer mal
wieder bei frischem wind und
temperaturen zwischen 9 und 16 grad
besonders im norden und osten zeigt sich
auch mal die sonne morgen tag der
deutschen einheit ein feiertag klar da
freut sich jeder der freiheit politisch
ist es ein tag an dem man sich fragen
kann wie weit wir den sinn mit der
einheit nach 30 jahren es gibt orte an
denen man dieser frage besonders gut
nachspüren kann etwa entlang des
sogenannten grünen bandes dort wo früher
die innerdeutsche grenze verlief
einschließlich todesstreifen spuren
davon finden sich bis heute
peter kunz in andreas postel sind diese
ehemalige grenze entlang gereist und
menschen begegnet die ihren blick auf
die einheit schilder grenzgänger heißt
die so entstandene doku von der wir
jetzt schon mal an auschwitz sei
die resterampe der deutschen
demokratischen republik der ehemalige
deutsch-deutsche todesstreifen
überraschend viele türme und sound
stücke haben bis heute überlebt als
mahnmal museum oder einfach ausgemustert
1393 kilometer war unser innerdeutsche
eiserner vorhang lang heute eine
verbindende wanderstrecke mit sehr
persönlichen geschichten
mein vater der wurde verhaftet 62 und
nur weil er sich die grenze anschauen
wollte und wir sind dankbar dass die
jetzt nicht mehr da ist und dass wir
hier lang laufen können auf diesen loch
betonplatten patroullierten die ddr
grenztruppen am todesstreifen die alte
ost west nord fordert die frage heraus
wo knirscht es noch nach 30 jahren
zusammen wachsen die spaltung zwischen
ost und west merkt man immer noch und
zwar an den ganzen löhne und gehälter
sind längst nicht die bei uns längst
nicht die in den westlichen ländern
unsere noch klagen über die anhaltende
ungleichheit bei den löhnen hören wir
oft auf unserer filmischen reise entlang
der ehemaligen grenze zwei zdf reporter
einer vor 30 jahren noch ein ossi der
andere ein wessi sind auf spurensuche
überlebt willi sittes elterliche hof im
sperrgebiet war beschlagnahmt worden
nach der wiedervereinigung bekam er ihn
zurück tausende häuser wurden abgerissen
nur damit die ddr die eigenen bürger mit
minenfeldern und schießbefehl einsperren
konnte und kann nicht durch arbeit hatte
hier aber inszeniert auch zu essen
würden darüber den kopf so
perspektivisch ist das trostlos gewesen
so war das aus für die ddr vor 30 jahren
erst mit maueröffnung dann mit
wiedervereinigung vielleicht das
konsequenteste ende der geschichte
dieser grenze trotz mancher ostalgie der
ganze frühere todesstreifen in neun
tagen läuft eine schüler staffel aus
wolfenbüttel die knapp 1400
kilometer ab junge menschen die nach
spüren was gesamtdeutsch wirklich heißt
sowas begreift man gut dem ehemals
geteilten dorf mödlareuth also
demokratie sehr wichtig für eine
gesellschaft ist aber hier wird es noch
mal sehr veranschaulicht also wie es
sein kann wenn es nicht so gut läuft
wenn es nicht so gut läuft mit der
freiheit die aber mauern und zäune
überwinden kann
die ganze doku können sie hier im zdf
morgen um 11.30 sehen vor der
übertragung des offiziellen festakt zum
tag der deutschen einheit
sie finden sie online aber auch schon
jetzt in der mediathek auf zdf.de
das war es von uns mit der
leichtathletik wm geht es weiter um 0.50
gibt es dann heute plus mit daniel
bröckerhoff in morgen einen schönen
feiertag auf wiedersehen
[Musik]